Hey guys, good morning. Welcome to Smartless. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
|*Hey guys, good morning. Welcome to Smartless. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
|Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
Smart. Less. Smart. Less it is. Classic. Listener, we've got Arnett with I guess a shirt you're borrowing from Thoreau. Yeah. There's no sleeves at all on it. And I guess Jimmy Coco just left too, huh? Cause your color's really even. Let me just say this.
|Smart. Less. Smart. Less it is. Classic. Listener, we've got Arnett with I guess a shirt you're borrowing from Thoreau. Yeah. There's no sleeves at all on it. And I guess Jimmy Coco just left too, huh? Cause your color's really even. Let me just say this.
Okay. Nothing is more insulting to me. Virtually nothing than suggesting that it's a spray tan. Go after yourself. I earned this. Well, you earned it by sitting out doing nothing under the sun with some sort of like a reflective board. What are you doing, building a stool you're sitting on?
|Okay. Nothing is more insulting to me. Virtually nothing than suggesting that it's a spray tan. Go after yourself. I earned this. Well, you earned it by sitting out doing nothing under the sun with some sort of like a reflective board. What are you doing, building a stool you're sitting on?
I'm just getting some cord. Yeah, can you get your housekeeping shit together before we start the record? What are you doing? I got some cord issues going on. I do too. I'm messing with mine. Kind of wrapped around my chair.
|I'm just getting some cord. Yeah, can you get your housekeeping shit together before we start the record? What are you doing? I got some cord issues going on. I do too. I'm messing with mine. Kind of wrapped around my chair.
Mine's pretty much. You know, you know what I've been doing lately, and this is a true story, we went to this big, I know this is gonna air later, but we had a beautiful event last night. For Jimmy Buffett. For my friend Jimmy Buffett. And it was just, it was awesome,
|Mine's pretty much. You know, you know what I've been doing lately, and this is a true story, we went to this big, I know this is gonna air later, but we had a beautiful event last night. For Jimmy Buffett. For my friend Jimmy Buffett. And it was just, it was awesome,
and it was really beautiful, and some great speeches and stuff. And a lot of people I know, so that part of it was amazing, and it just, Did you talk? Honestly, I did not. I did a thing at the tribute at the Hollywood Bowl, but last time I did, I saw one of the great speeches
|and it was really beautiful, and some great speeches and stuff. And a lot of people I know, so that part of it was amazing, and it just, Did you talk? Honestly, I did not. I did a thing at the tribute at the Hollywood Bowl, but last time I did, I saw one of the great speeches
last night that Downey. No, no, Downey wasn't there. One of the great speeches I've ever seen as a sort of, that was set up as a non-roast and ended up being a roast, and it really blew me away, so hilarious. I love those. Wait, roasted Jimmy after he's passed? Yeah, but as a tribute to him,
|last night that Downey. No, no, Downey wasn't there. One of the great speeches I've ever seen as a sort of, that was set up as a non-roast and ended up being a roast, and it really blew me away, so hilarious. I love those. Wait, roasted Jimmy after he's passed? Yeah, but as a tribute to him,
an old friend of his, a guy who's been friends with him for sort of 50, 60 years, and it was just, it was so good. And our friend Tom Freston, who's a friend of the podcast, made a great speech that was hilarious. You haven't had him on yet. No, I'm going to. He's the most interesting man on the planet.
|an old friend of his, a guy who's been friends with him for sort of 50, 60 years, and it was just, it was so good. And our friend Tom Freston, who's a friend of the podcast, made a great speech that was hilarious. You haven't had him on yet. No, I'm going to. He's the most interesting man on the planet.
Who's Tom Freston? Can't make his deal? Can't, well we're looking to, cause he wants a piece and he's just like, oh, and he said send me over the numbers, I wanna look and see. Wait, who's Tom Freston? I met Tom Freston.
|Who's Tom Freston? Can't make his deal? Can't, well we're looking to, cause he wants a piece and he's just like, oh, and he said send me over the numbers, I wanna look and see. Wait, who's Tom Freston? I met Tom Freston.
Mr. Run MTV. Tom Freston, yeah, he started MTV. Oh yes, I totally know him. He's awesome. And then, dude, his stories are, he's just the best. Well, we'll see, you can book him. I think he's writing a book right now, which it'll be, anyway, yeah, it was just, it was so, so, so good.
|Mr. Run MTV. Tom Freston, yeah, he started MTV. Oh yes, I totally know him. He's awesome. And then, dude, his stories are, he's just the best. Well, we'll see, you can book him. I think he's writing a book right now, which it'll be, anyway, yeah, it was just, it was so, so, so good.
But the reason I brought it up was this. At this thing, mid-summer, and so many people, and now this many people come up to me and they go, either, wow, you're really tan, or why are you so tan, right? And people can't help themselves but make a personal remark. And you know what I do?
|But the reason I brought it up was this. At this thing, mid-summer, and so many people, and now this many people come up to me and they go, either, wow, you're really tan, or why are you so tan, right? And people can't help themselves but make a personal remark. And you know what I do?
You know what I say? And I go, and I go, they'll go, wow, you're so tan, and I'll go, thank you so much. Right. And I just take it as a compliment. Well, it is a compliment. You hold color like you're from Brazil. I don't understand it.
|You know what I say? And I go, and I go, they'll go, wow, you're so tan, and I'll go, thank you so much. Right. And I just take it as a compliment. Well, it is a compliment. You hold color like you're from Brazil. I don't understand it.
You're from Toronto. You know, like why do you color so well? But both you guys know me. I'm a walking bounce card. Yeah, we would just burn immediately. But JB, you hold quite a bit of color too. Let's be honest, when you play golf, you're gonna be tan. But I don't say to you every day, man, you're so tan.
|You're from Toronto. You know, like why do you color so well? But both you guys know me. I'm a walking bounce card. Yeah, we would just burn immediately. But JB, you hold quite a bit of color too. Let's be honest, when you play golf, you're gonna be tan. But I don't say to you every day, man, you're so tan.
When we got... But mine's, sorry Sean, hold it. God. I know. Fuck. We're talking about our color in our golf game. You'll wait. My color is, it's got a hard V right under the chin, right?
|When we got... But mine's, sorry Sean, hold it. God. I know. Fuck. We're talking about our color in our golf game. You'll wait. My color is, it's got a hard V right under the chin, right?
From the hot shirts I wear. And then the little, you know, where the short sleeve ends, whatever that is, there's that tan line. And then there's the forehead tan line, because I'm wearing a sporty visor. Yours is like you're outside mowing the lawn with nothing on but like flip flops. Yeah, I know.
|From the hot shirts I wear. And then the little, you know, where the short sleeve ends, whatever that is, there's that tan line. And then there's the forehead tan line, because I'm wearing a sporty visor. Yours is like you're outside mowing the lawn with nothing on but like flip flops. Yeah, I know.
First of all, everybody's... Sean, god damn it. Are people okay with their bones with you describing your V-neck dad, Bob Dan? We just had a bone epidemic. But you know what it is, I spend a lot of time, like you know me, you guys, I'm not like out in the Caribbean, actually I was last month.
|First of all, everybody's... Sean, god damn it. Are people okay with their bones with you describing your V-neck dad, Bob Dan? We just had a bone epidemic. But you know what it is, I spend a lot of time, like you know me, you guys, I'm not like out in the Caribbean, actually I was last month.
But I'm at the pool with the kids. I was in the Caribbean a month ago, so that's part of it. And we got it. Sean, go for Sean. Well, I have this friend who tans his taint. Oh! Yeah, that's like a thing. Is it really?
|But I'm at the pool with the kids. I was in the Caribbean a month ago, so that's part of it. And we got it. Sean, go for Sean. Well, I have this friend who tans his taint. Oh! Yeah, that's like a thing. Is it really?
So you like you tan completely naked. Wait, is that like bleaching? I don't know. No, man. Oh, that's where you draw the line. I know about tanning the asshole, but not about bleaching. Yeah, I don't know anything about bleaching. Yeah, how dare you?
|So you like you tan completely naked. Wait, is that like bleaching? I don't know. No, man. Oh, that's where you draw the line. I know about tanning the asshole, but not about bleaching. Yeah, I don't know anything about bleaching. Yeah, how dare you?
Fuck. Here we come. This is a great, great segue into our high class guest. Gang, our guest this week is enormously accomplished in two completely separate but very public careers and has done so while remaining incredibly private and avoiding for the most part all the trappings of a Hollywood life.
|Fuck. Here we come. This is a great, great segue into our high class guest. Gang, our guest this week is enormously accomplished in two completely separate but very public careers and has done so while remaining incredibly private and avoiding for the most part all the trappings of a Hollywood life.
He's an actor and a musician, you two, not a celebrity and a rock star, okay? In the movie world, he's received numerous nominations and awards including an Oscar, a SAG, a Golden Globe. He's worked with some of the greatest directors of our time, including Fincher, Malick, Stone, Aronofsky, Villeneuve. As a musician, he's been the front man of his band for over 26 years. They've sold over 50 million albums and toured the world multiple times.
|He's an actor and a musician, you two, not a celebrity and a rock star, okay? In the movie world, he's received numerous nominations and awards including an Oscar, a SAG, a Golden Globe. He's worked with some of the greatest directors of our time, including Fincher, Malick, Stone, Aronofsky, Villeneuve. As a musician, he's been the front man of his band for over 26 years. They've sold over 50 million albums and toured the world multiple times.
He's quietly been deeply involved in charity and the business world and the few remaining free minutes in his life. He's funny, he's easy on the eyes, he's a Capricorn and I believe he's available. Let's help him out guys, this is Jared Leto. Leto, I just saw him! Oh, Jared Leto! I called it!
|He's quietly been deeply involved in charity and the business world and the few remaining free minutes in his life. He's funny, he's easy on the eyes, he's a Capricorn and I believe he's available. Let's help him out guys, this is Jared Leto. Leto, I just saw him! Oh, Jared Leto! I called it!
Oh, hello, hello, hello. Hey man. Jared, hi. I'm proud to say Jared and I know each other a little bit. I wish I was closer friends with him. I was gonna ask. But you know, he's busy, you know. Where do we find you?
|Oh, hello, hello, hello. Hey man. Jared, hi. I'm proud to say Jared and I know each other a little bit. I wish I was closer friends with him. I was gonna ask. But you know, he's busy, you know. Where do we find you?
You find me in Iowa today. Oh really? Are we acting or are we musicianing? We just started the US leg of our world tour, which is called Seasons World Tour. Shout out to Tracy in Wisconsin. Thank you very much. season's world tour. And shout out to Tracy in Wisconsin. We were in Wisconsin. Thank you very much, thank you. Yeah, last two shows we were in Milwaukee
|You find me in Iowa today. Oh really? Are we acting or are we musicianing? We just started the US leg of our world tour, which is called Seasons World Tour. Shout out to Tracy in Wisconsin. Thank you very much. season's world tour. And shout out to Tracy in Wisconsin. We were in Wisconsin. Thank you very much, thank you. Yeah, last two shows we were in Milwaukee
and then in Cadot. Oh wow. Wait, what's Cadot? Yeah, what's Cadot? Cadot is a beautiful little town in the middle of nowhere and today we're in Des Moines. So wait, is Cadot in Wisconsin? Yeah. All right. Wait,, is Kedat in Wisconsin? Yeah.
|and then in Cadot. Oh wow. Wait, what's Cadot? Yeah, what's Cadot? Cadot is a beautiful little town in the middle of nowhere and today we're in Des Moines. So wait, is Cadot in Wisconsin? Yeah. All right. Wait,, is Kedat in Wisconsin? Yeah.
All right. Wait, how do you guys know each other? How, just sort of crossing paths throughout our start as youngsters in the biz? Is that true? I think so. Or vacationing. I think, was the first time on our little trip to Ski Town?
|All right. Wait, how do you guys know each other? How, just sort of crossing paths throughout our start as youngsters in the biz? Is that true? I think so. Or vacationing. I think, was the first time on our little trip to Ski Town?
I have no idea, man. I think maybe, I don't know. But I've been very fond of you for a very long time, mister. Likewise. And I'm so glad to be able to talk to you. Yeah, it's so cool. I'm focused for an hour here. Yeah, this is awesome.
|I have no idea, man. I think maybe, I don't know. But I've been very fond of you for a very long time, mister. Likewise. And I'm so glad to be able to talk to you. Yeah, it's so cool. I'm focused for an hour here. Yeah, this is awesome.
I appreciate it. And this is actually my, I think it's my first podcast that I've ever done. It's ours too. Really? So, yeah. I'm gonna fuck it up big time. Listen, Jared, here's the thing with podcasts.
|I appreciate it. And this is actually my, I think it's my first podcast that I've ever done. It's ours too. Really? So, yeah. I'm gonna fuck it up big time. Listen, Jared, here's the thing with podcasts.
Just try to get a word in. If I can say anything about podcasts, this is the first time any of us had done one. We started it four years ago, and we have not got any better. I would say we've gotten worse. I would say. I wore some pajamas I thought someone might be in the pajama.
|Just try to get a word in. If I can say anything about podcasts, this is the first time any of us had done one. We started it four years ago, and we have not got any better. I would say we've gotten worse. I would say. I wore some pajamas I thought someone might be in the pajama.
Yeah, look at me. Here's the stretchy pajama pants, and the fucking hoodie, and the shittyama. Yeah, look at me, here's the stretchy pajama pants and the fucking hoodie and the shitty t-shirt. Jared, before we jump into how brilliant you are in your music and your acting, you're so good looking, what do you do for your skin? Good Lord. And this is for Jared or this is for everybody?
|Yeah, look at me. Here's the stretchy pajama pants, and the fucking hoodie, and the shittyama. Yeah, look at me, here's the stretchy pajama pants and the fucking hoodie and the shitty t-shirt. Jared, before we jump into how brilliant you are in your music and your acting, you're so good looking, what do you do for your skin? Good Lord. And this is for Jared or this is for everybody?
We're done with your skin. No, it's kind of amazing. Jared, how old are you? Are you over 50? 52. That's what I'm saying. Shut the fuck up. You look great.
|We're done with your skin. No, it's kind of amazing. Jared, how old are you? Are you over 50? 52. That's what I'm saying. Shut the fuck up. You look great.
You guys look great. What are you talking about? Yeah, I mean, honestly, you could play, and I mean this, and I love everybody here, including you, Jared, cause now you're with us. You could play Jason's son. And I swear you could. you could play Jason's son. And I swear you could.
|You guys look great. What are you talking about? Yeah, I mean, honestly, you could play, and I mean this, and I love everybody here, including you, Jared, cause now you're with us. You could play Jason's son. And I swear you could. you could play Jason's son. And I swear you could.
But you know, he wears it much better than me. I'm... No, that's what I'm saying. No, that's what I'm saying. I'm saying he could play your son. All right, so Jared, so you're starting the domestic leg of the international tour or world tour. But this is, what lap around the planet
|But you know, he wears it much better than me. I'm... No, that's what I'm saying. No, that's what I'm saying. I'm saying he could play your son. All right, so Jared, so you're starting the domestic leg of the international tour or world tour. But this is, what lap around the planet
would this be for you guys? You've done it a few times. Yeah, six or 700 probably. No, no, not six or 700 laps. No, no, I'm joking. But we started, we actually didn't tour for about six years. It was COVID and then we were finishing an album.
|would this be for you guys? You've done it a few times. Yeah, six or 700 probably. No, no, not six or 700 laps. No, no, I'm joking. But we started, we actually didn't tour for about six years. It was COVID and then we were finishing an album.
So the last time we did a world tour was like 2018, did some dates in 2019. But we just, we did a few festivals last year and then we started this year I was filming Tron in Vancouver for four months. I can't wait for that. Can't wait too easy. And then I had a couple of weeks where we went
|So the last time we did a world tour was like 2018, did some dates in 2019. But we just, we did a few festivals last year and then we started this year I was filming Tron in Vancouver for four months. I can't wait for that. Can't wait too easy. And then I had a couple of weeks where we went
to South America to start the tour. and then after Tron was done, we went off to Europe and just did seven, eight weeks in Europe. Wait, wait, wait, wait, Jared, I don't know if you guys saw it. Did you start, did you announce your tour? Did I see this? Did you climb the Empire State Building or some shit? Yeah, I saw that. What the fuck is that? Just start, just go ahead and take 45 minutes to tell us about this. Empire State Building or some shit? Yeah, I saw that. What the fuck is that about, man?
|to South America to start the tour. and then after Tron was done, we went off to Europe and just did seven, eight weeks in Europe. Wait, wait, wait, wait, Jared, I don't know if you guys saw it. Did you start, did you announce your tour? Did I see this? Did you climb the Empire State Building or some shit? Yeah, I saw that. What the fuck is that? Just start, just go ahead and take 45 minutes to tell us about this. Empire State Building or some shit? Yeah, I saw that. What the fuck is that about, man?
Just go ahead and take 45 minutes to tell us about this. Yeah, please. Just a little stunt to launch the tour. I mean, it's better than just putting it on Twitter. No, exactly. But, how did you not vomit? Well, don't jump ahead. Who comes up with this idea?
|Just go ahead and take 45 minutes to tell us about this. Yeah, please. Just a little stunt to launch the tour. I mean, it's better than just putting it on Twitter. No, exactly. But, how did you not vomit? Well, don't jump ahead. Who comes up with this idea?
Let's talk about planning. First of all, you're a rock climber. So this wasn't out of the blue. Is it rock star? No, I mean, I've climbed buildings before and I've always been obsessed with, yeah, I mean, just obviously not like that, but I've always been really fascinated
|Let's talk about planning. First of all, you're a rock climber. So this wasn't out of the blue. Is it rock star? No, I mean, I've climbed buildings before and I've always been obsessed with, yeah, I mean, just obviously not like that, but I've always been really fascinated
by the Empire State Building since I was a kid. Oh wow, you and King Kong, right? Just like, I gotta get up there. So how does that, all right, as I did a tiny bit of rock climbing with my dad when I was a kid, enough to know that it's a certain kind of shoe, it's a boot, it's a friction boot, I think it's called, maybe something like that.
|by the Empire State Building since I was a kid. Oh wow, you and King Kong, right? Just like, I gotta get up there. So how does that, all right, as I did a tiny bit of rock climbing with my dad when I was a kid, enough to know that it's a certain kind of shoe, it's a boot, it's a friction boot, I think it's called, maybe something like that.
No, not at all, but that's okay. This is close. But you need some- It's called a rock climbing shoe. Yeah, that's it. I'm gonna write that down. And you need some sort of, something jutting out of a flat surface
|No, not at all, but that's okay. This is close. But you need some- It's called a rock climbing shoe. Yeah, that's it. I'm gonna write that down. And you need some sort of, something jutting out of a flat surface
to be able to kind of get some kind of a grip onto. A building, almost by definition, is flat. So what makes you think, you've climbed multiple buildings, well, how do you get up there? How do you do it? Windows sills, if there's kind of a stone feature, use those. But a lot of times it's just the structure, the features on the building. But were you hooked into something or were you just freestyling?
|to be able to kind of get some kind of a grip onto. A building, almost by definition, is flat. So what makes you think, you've climbed multiple buildings, well, how do you get up there? How do you do it? Windows sills, if there's kind of a stone feature, use those. But a lot of times it's just the structure, the features on the building. But were you hooked into something or were you just freestyling?
Yeah, yeah. I mean, we went to the Empire State Building But it was fun, man. It was an incredible adventure. And to sit up there for, you know, we actually did it two days in a row, kind of a day to climb it, another day to film it. But it was amazing. So, wait, so you're standing on the sidewalk,
|Yeah, yeah. I mean, we went to the Empire State Building But it was fun, man. It was an incredible adventure. And to sit up there for, you know, we actually did it two days in a row, kind of a day to climb it, another day to film it. But it was amazing. So, wait, so you're standing on the sidewalk,
you're scouting it, right? You gotta take a look at it up close first. And you recognize that there is a path, that it is doable, that in other words, that first window sill, you can literally reach and start your climb. I mean, stuff like that, I just... Yeah. The first step.
|you're scouting it, right? You gotta take a look at it up close first. And you recognize that there is a path, that it is doable, that in other words, that first window sill, you can literally reach and start your climb. I mean, stuff like that, I just... Yeah. The first step.
I was just gonna say the first step. Yeah, yeah, the first step is getting them to say yes, getting permits to be able to do it. But they didn't, right? You know, no, they did. Oh. Because I think, you know what their big concern actually was? Was it necessarily me falling?
|I was just gonna say the first step. Yeah, yeah, the first step is getting them to say yes, getting permits to be able to do it. But they didn't, right? You know, no, they did. Oh. Because I think, you know what their big concern actually was? Was it necessarily me falling?
No, it was me falling on top of somebody and killing somebody. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, that makes sense. But I had some climber friends of mine that looked at it. A guy named Alex Honnold from Free Solo took a look at doing that at one point. And had decided really that the first section of it was probably not climbable unless you wanted to die. But the only way that I was able to do it was to get permission to get permits
不，是我掉到别人身上，然后把别人砸死了。哦，对，对，对，那确实说得通。不过我有些攀岩的朋友看过这个。有一个叫亚历克斯·霍诺德的人，就是《徒手攀岩》里的那个，他曾一度考虑过要不要在帝国大厦做这件事。最后他真的觉得，第一段基本上是没法爬的，除非你想死。但我唯一能做到这一点的方法，是我得到了许可，拿到了许可证，
and I had to be roped up for the sections that I climbed, the sections that were climbable. But it was amazing. So then you were gonna free climb it? Yeah, I mean, look, there's a lot of terminology that gets confusing with climbing, that were climbable, but it was amazing. Wait, so then you were gonna free climb it? Yeah, I mean, look, there's a lot of terminology that gets confusing with climbing, but yeah, I had to be roped up
而且在我攀爬的那些路段——那些可以攀爬的路段，我必须系着安全绳。但这太不可思议了。所以你当时打算无绳徒手攀登？对，我是说，你看，攀岩里有很多容易让人混淆的术语，那些可以攀爬的路段，但它太不可思议了。等等，所以你当时打算无绳徒手攀登？对，我是说，你看，攀岩里有很多容易让人混淆的术语，但对，我必须系着安全绳，
while I climbed the Empire State Building. Had I not, I would be dead because I did fall. And it's a very, very difficult climb. It's not something that you can just kind of do without a rope. Jared, do you know that every night, and this is true, Jason, you'll attest to this, every single night you get roped up, right?
在我攀爬帝国大厦的时候。如果我不系，我早就没命了，因为我确实掉下去过。那是一次非常非常艰难的攀爬。这不是那种你可以不系绳子就随随便便去完成的事情。杰瑞德，你知道吗，每天晚上——千真万确，杰森，你可以作证——每天晚上你都会被绳子绑着，对吧？
You don't smoke it, I guess you chew it. But you get a head full of rope every night. Wait a second, so Jared, I've seen a lot of those. I loved all those like Free Solo and the other one about the guys who climbed in Tibet, all those amazing Sherpas until you know that story they climbed all those peaks What was that one? They climbed like the seven peaks was it? Yeah? Yeah, it's called something like that. Yes, I mean, but but but Sort of that the kind of the the the one consistent thing about all of them was that they just had this
你不用抽的，我猜你是嚼的。但你每天晚上满脑子都是绳子。等一下，所以杰瑞德，我看过很多那种纪录片。我很喜欢所有那些像《徒手攀岩》以及另一部关于在西藏攀岩的那部，所有那些了不起的夏尔巴人，直到你知道他们爬了所有那些山峰的故事……那部叫什么来着？他们爬了七大峰什么的？对吧？对，对，好像就叫这个名字。对，我的意思是，但是，但是，但是，所有这些片子都有一个共同点，就是他们身上都有那种……
That thing that I don't think most people have, which I guess you have, which is that, sort of, they're missing that thing of having fear that most of us have, which, that I have, I start to get weak, my knees get weak when I climb a ladder that's above 10 feet, you know what I mean? When I'm like, fuck man, if I fall, I'm gonna die.
那种我觉得大多数人都没有、而你身上大概有的特质，就是那种，他们似乎没有我们大多数人都有的恐惧感，而我有的那种恐惧——当我爬一块十英尺以上的梯子时，我的双腿就会开始发软，你知道我的意思吗？当我心想，妈的，老兄，如果我掉下去，我就会死。
And so my question is for you is, because all those people seem to have it, and you have it, did you always have that? Or did you kind of, did it just over time develop? No, I still get, yeah, I experience fear when I'm climbing all the time. I mean, that's what keeps you alive. But I climb with Alex quite a bit.
所以我的问题是，因为所有那些人似乎都有这种特质，而你也有，你一直都有这种特质吗？还是说你这种特质是随着时间推移慢慢培养出来的？不，我还是会，是的，我攀岩时一直都会感到恐惧。我的意思，正是这种恐惧救了你的命。但我经常和亚历克斯一起攀岩。
He's a good friend. I climb with Jimmy Chen, who's about to go to... I think he's going to ski down Everest or something crazy. No way. But yeah, these guys, you know, they're professionals. I'm an amateur. You know, I do this for fun. It's a hobby for me.
他是个好朋友。我和吉米·陈一起攀岩，他正准备去……我想他要去滑雪下珠穆朗玛峰还是干点什么疯狂的事。不会吧。但对，这些家伙，你知道，他们是专业人士。我只是个业余爱好者。你知道，我做这个是为了好玩。对我来说这只是个爱好。
But there are a lot of times you have to negotiate with fear. You have to have a conversation with yourself. And it's a fascinating thing because you're, I've never heard people talk about death more than friends of mine that are climbing all the time. It's a common, you're really close to death and I think in a way you're really also maybe a bit closer to life.
但有很多时候你必须跟恐惧进行交涉。你必须和自己对话。这是一件很迷人的事，因为你，我从来没有听谁像我那些经常攀岩的朋友那样频繁地谈论死亡。这是一种常态，你真的离死亡很近，而且我觉得在某种程度上，你可能也离生活更近了一点。
I free dive as well and you know, that's something where you're always having a conversation with yourself about negotiating your limits, negotiating fear. But I don't know, I love it. I think it. I think it's really fun at the end of the day, it's just fun. Is there any time that you actually got really close to that moment of death? Oh yeah, I was climbing with Alex in Red Rock, where I live.
我也玩自由潜水，你知道，那也是一种你一直在和自己对话、在摸索自身极限、在克服恐惧的活动。但我不知道，我很喜欢它。我觉得它。我觉得归根结底它真的很有趣，这只是一件好玩的事。你有没有哪次真的离死亡那么近过？哦，对，我跟亚历克斯在红岩（Red Rock）攀岩时遇到过，我就住在那里。
I live in Nevada now, by the way, I moved there during COVID. Oh wow. And I lived 10 minutes from some of the best rock climbing in the world, and I was out there climbing with him one day, and my rope got cut. Oh, my God. And I was about... On a rock? I was about, yeah, 600 feet up, about to...
顺便说一句，我现在住在内华达州，我是新冠疫情期间搬过去的。哦，哇。我住的地方离世界上一些最好的攀岩圣地只有10分钟车程，有一天我和他在那里攀岩，我的绳子被割断了。哦，天哪。我当时大约……在岩壁上？我当时大约，是的，在600英尺的高空，正准备……
I was climbing an overhang about 600 feet off the ground, and I knew I was gonna fall, which is actually, you know, pretty normal in climbing. You sometimes was gonna fall, which is actually, you know, pretty normal in climbing. You sometimes, you fall a couple of times and that's how you learn, that's how you get better, that's how you kind of make it through. And just, and for Tracy, like, you fall but you don't fall to the ground because you've got a carabiner into the rock at some sort of place, so you're only falling that distance,
我当时正在爬一个约离地面600英尺的屋檐状岩壁，我知道自己要掉下去了，这其实，你知道的，在攀岩里是很正常的。你有时，会掉下去几次，这就是你学习的方式，这就是你进步的方式，这就是你闯过难关的方式。而且，对崔茜来说，你掉下去但不会摔到地面上，因为你在某个地方把铁锁挂进了岩石里，所以你只会坠落那么一段距离，
which is maybe, what, 20 feet, something like that? Exactly, sometimes it could be 50 feet, it could be two feet, it really depends on the situation. But Alex was ahead of me and he was placing the gear. I took a fall, I swung out over the 600 foot abyss, and as I was swinging, I felt the rope go pop, pop, pop, pop. No way. And I looked up and I could see it started to get core shot at the top.
大概是多少，20英尺，诸如此类的？没错，有时可能是50英尺，有时可能是2英尺，这真的取决于当时的情况。但亚历克斯在我前面，他在放置装备。我失足坠落，荡在了600英尺深的深渊上方，就在我荡来荡去的时候，我感觉到绳子发出“砰、砰、砰、砰”的声音。不会吧。我抬头一看，发现顶部的绳芯已经露出来了。
I saw the white innards of the rope pop out. No. And I knew in those few seconds, milliseconds, maybe that I was probably going to die. And if if I didn't grab a hold of the wall when I swung back in, I was that was it. So I swung back into the wall and I went to grab it at the last minute. Oh, I lost it.
我看到绳子白色的内芯爆了出来。不会吧。在那几秒钟里——也许只是毫秒之间——我知道自己可能死定了。如果我荡回来时没有抓住岩壁，那就彻底完蛋了。所以我荡回岩壁，在最后一刻伸手去抓。哦，我没抓住。
And I swung out again, but I yelled, lower me to Alex. Unfortunately, he heard me. It was a very windy day and he was about a hundred feet above me on top of this mountain because he couldn't see me. I was on the overhang.
我又荡了出去，但我大喊：“把我放下去！”喊给亚历克斯听。不幸的是，他听到了。那天风很大，他在我头顶大约一百英尺的这座山顶上，因为他看不见我。我在那个屋檐状的岩壁下面。
And as I said, yelled, lower me, he lowered. So the next time that the rope got me. I was on the overhang. And as I said, y'all lower me. He lowered so the next time that the rope got cut, it was in a different spot. And that time I managed to make it on the wall. And he figured out how to get down because he's superhuman. And we had to cut the rope and kind of negotiate our way down the mountain. But it was, yeah, that was pretty fun. Yeah, and then like, wow.
正如我所说，我大喊“把我放下”，他就把我往下放了。所以下一次绳子出问题的时候，它是在一个不同的地方。那一次我设法抓住了岩壁。他想办法下来了，因为他简直不是人。我们不得不割断绳子，一路摸索着下了山。但那次，是的，挺好玩的。对，然后，哇。
Dude, I would have been, first of all, all the clothing I was wearing would have to be thrown out. Yeah, right. Right. It would be, my pants would be filled with defecate. Sean, one time, what was the thing, Sean, you said at the Grove, you and Scotty parked on P4, and you ended up taking the stairs all the way down, right?
老兄，我当时，首先，我身上穿的所有衣服都得扔掉了。对，没错。没错，我的裤子里会装满排泄物。肖恩，有一次，那是怎么回事来着，肖恩，你在格罗夫（The Grove）购物中心说的那次，你和斯科蒂把车停在P4停车场，结果你们一路走楼梯下去了，对吧？
Because the elevators broken Yeah, that's right. Yeah, that was my scariest moment. That was the story At the end of it Alex is like you want to do it again. I was like you're out of your fucking mind Yeah, right. It's me, right? Yeah And we will be right back And now back to the show But Jared talk to me about how you, what is that conversation with yourself when you negotiate with yourself about fear?
因为电梯坏了。对，没错。对，那是我最害怕的时刻。那就是那个故事。最后亚历克斯问：“你还想再来一次吗？”我说：“你他妈疯了吧。”对，没错。是我，对吧？对。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。不过杰瑞德，跟我谈谈你是怎么做的，当你和自己对话、跟恐惧做交涉时，你内心是怎么进行这种对话的？
Because I'm sure it's not just exclusive to rock climbing. It's about, you know, getting up in front of thousands and thousands of people, performing with 30 Seconds to Mars, or taking on some of these incredibly ambitious roles which you pull off like no one's business. What is that, how is, I mean, I know it's a deeply personal conversation people have with themselves about kind of gearing up for stuff and asking yourself to give what you got.
因为我确信这不仅仅局限于攀岩。这还关于，你知道的，站在成千上万的人面前，和“三十秒到火星”乐队一起表演，或者接演一些极具雄心、被你演绎得无可挑剔的角色。那是什么，那是怎么……我的意思，我知道人们在为事情做准备、要求自己倾尽所有时，都会和自己进行一种非常私密的对话。
But give us as much as you're comfortable giving about, because you clearly have a lot of, it's not confidence, it's just, it's, you tell me what it is, because you have it. Well, I mean, thank you, I appreciate it, but I think you guys do that all the time. I mean, some of the scariest stuff.
但请尽可能多地跟我们分享你的感受，因为你显然有很多——这不是自信，这只是，你来告诉我这是什么，因为你身上有这种特质。好吧，我是说，谢谢，我很感激，但我认为你们也一直在做这种事。我是说，有些事情是最可怕的。
It's different, it's different. I appreciate it, but I think you guys do that all the time. I mean, some of the scariest stuff. You know what can scare me more than a lot of things is having to speak in front of a lot of people. Yeah, I don't do that well. Up on stage with a spotlight, as myself, with a microphone. It's bizarre because I'm on stage most nights of the week, as you are as well. And even this is a public stage. It's...
这不一样，这不一样。我很感激，但我觉得你们也一直在做这种事。我是说，有些事情是最可怕的。你知道什么比很多事情更让我害怕吗，那就是不得不在很多人面前演讲。对，我不擅长这个。站在有聚光灯的舞台上，以我自己的身份，拿着麦克风。这很诡异，因为我一周的大多数晚上都在舞台上，你也是。甚至连这也是个公共舞台。这……
You know, so that can always, you know, when you're just up there and it's you and your words, that can be a little intimidating. But I don't know, I think, you know, there's an inevitability. Like when I'm on tour, you have to go on stage. And the weird thing about being... Maybe you guys have felt this as well. I feel more comfortable on stage
你知道，所以那总是会，你知道的，当你站在上面，只有你和你的言语时，那会有点吓人。但我不知道，我想，你知道，这是不可避免的。就像我在巡演时，你必须上台。而这种感觉很奇怪——也许你们也有过这种感觉。我觉得在舞台上比坐在。
than I do sitting here talking to you or I would talking to a person at dinner. Like I feel, once the show is done. Because that's a character maybe? No, no, no, no, no. Lead man? No, no, no, music is, being on stage is a total opposite. It's the revelation of oneself.
这里跟你说话，或者在晚宴上跟一个人说话要自在得多。我觉得，一旦演出结束……因为那也许是个角色？不，不，不，不，不。主唱吗？不，不，不，音乐是……在舞台上完全是另一回事。那是对自我的揭示。
It's showing and sharing who you really are. You know what? Yeah. No, really quick, I was just gonna say, at my wedding to Scotty, my husband, there was like 10 people at our wedding. We were gonna do like a thousand. And my opening, in my wedding vows, I said,
那是展现和分享真正的你。你知道吗？对。等等，说真的，我刚想说，在我跟我的丈夫斯科蒂的婚礼上，婚礼上大概只有10个人。我们本打算办一场一千人的。我在婚礼誓词的开场白里说，
I feel incredibly comfortable in front of thousands of people or one person, but this is right in the middle of that, and that's where I feel the worst. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, sometimes I have acoustic guitar, I'm sitting there in the middle of an arena or somewhere, and it just feels, you know, known. It feels absolutely amazing, it's so comfortable,
我在成千上万的人或一个人面前会感到非常自在，但现在这种场面正好介于两者之间，而这正是我感觉最糟糕的地方。对，对，对。对，有时我拿着木吉他，坐在体育场中央或者某个地方，那种感觉，你知道，很熟悉。感觉绝对太棒了，非常舒适，
it's so, I'm totally at peace and it's a magical thing. By the way, we're all this similar ages and I have to say I was talking to my brother and my brother's a massive fan of the show. Oh, no, I know your brother a little bit. I have a listener, he's been telling me from the very beginning, you gotta listen to the show. You gotta listen, texting me all the time, oh my God,
非常……我完全处于平静之中，这是一种神奇的感觉。顺便说一句，我们年纪都差不多，我必须说，我当时在跟我弟弟聊天，我弟弟是这个节目的超级粉丝。哦，不，我跟你的弟弟有点交情。我有位听众，他从一开始就告诉我，你得听这个节目。你得听，整天发信息对我说，天哪，
this happened on the show, because I call Cam and I listen to the goddamn show. Wait, Jared, you know that I know Shannon, we have mutual friends, I know Shannon a little bit. He's a great guy. For people that don't know that or listening, he's the better half of 30 Seconds to Mars, and we've been doing the band together since we were kids.
节目里发生这个了，因为我打电话给坎姆，然后我去听了这该死的节目。等等，杰瑞德，你知道我认识香农，我们有共同的朋友，我跟香农也算有点交情。他是个很棒的人。对于那些不知道或者在收听节目的听众来说，他是“三十秒到火星”乐队的顶梁柱，我们从很小的时候就一起组乐队了。
That's so great. And to be 52 at this point and to be on the road with your brother, there's not a night that goes by where I don't look at him and just share a moment of gratitude how lucky we are. I wanna come back to that, but before we leave this thing, is it, just so I sort of close the loop on it, it sounds like what you're saying is there's a belief
太棒了。在52岁这个年纪还能和弟弟一起在路上巡演，没有哪个晚上我看着他时，不涌起一股感激之情，感恩我们是多么幸运。我想回到刚才那个话题，但在我们离开这个话题之前，为了让我把这个思路做个收尾，听起来你的意思是，有一种信念，
in yourself that you find at the most critical moments that fuels you through something that might be insurmountable to some others that might not have that level of belief, your ability to go through something that might be really super challenging, is that what it is? I'm of the thinking that I actually don't
你在最关键的时刻在自己身上找到了这种信念，它能支撑你度过对其他人来说可能无法逾越的难关——那些可能没有你这种程度信念的人，而你拥有克服极具挑战性事情的能力，是这样的吗？我一直认为，其实我并没有
have anything special to offer. I really believe that everyone could basically do anything that I do anytime they want to. It's a matter of a little bit of faith and a lot of hard work. That's how I look at it. I think everybody could. But what's the faith?
什么特别的东西可以奉献。我真的相信，任何人基本上随时都可以做任何我能做的事。这只需要一点点信念和大量的努力。我是这么看的。我觉得每个人都可以。但信念是什么？
I guess that's the part. It's faith in yourself, right? It's belief that you can get it done and that you have the opportunity to make yourself proud and you're probably not gonna let yourself down. And the people around you too, you know? The people around you, that's a big driver for me is to kind of, to make sure I don't let anyone down.
我想这就是关键所在。是对自己的信念，对吧？是你相信自己能把事情做好，你有机会让自己引以为傲，而且你大概不会让自己失望。还有你周围的人，你知道吗？你身边的人，这是推动我前进的一大动力，那就是确保我不会让任何人失望。
Whether I'm working on a film or I'm on stage. And you know, the great thing that I found out about being on tour, being on stage is, like I'm not there for me. I'm there for the audience and for my brother, and I am in service every night to make sure the person that worked their ass off to buy a concert ticket, which aren't cheap these days,
无论我是在拍电影还是在舞台上。你知道，我关于巡演、关于上台的一大发现是，我不是为了自己才站在那里的。我是为了观众，为了我弟弟，我每天晚上都在为确保那些拼了命挣钱买演唱会门票——现在的门票可不便宜，
by the way, has a night that they're never gonna forget. And I'm in search of that every night, all night, and that's a lucky place to be. It's interesting you say that, and I think it's, I also have a similar thought process, which is that there are a thousand people who can do what I do. And I think about it all the time.
顺便说一句——的人能度过一个永生难忘的夜晚而服务。我每天晚上、整晚都在追求这个，能处于这个位置是很幸运的。你这么说很有趣，而且我觉得，我也有类似的思考过程，那就是有成千上万的人能做我做的事。我一直在这么想。
Might be a bigger number. It, pfft. And. And. And. But sorry, I'm gonna cut you off. within within within the greater Los Angeles area at any given time sorry So I will finish your boy No, no, no, no
这个数字可能更大。它，噗。而且。而且。而且。但抱歉，我要打断你一下。在任何特定时间的洛杉矶大都会区内……抱歉，那我来把你的话说完……不，不，不，不，
Listen I get it, you're hungry. I'm sorry. So, so, so, but what I wanted to know about was, when you say, it's interesting when you say, like you don't want to disappoint anybody, you want to let anybody down, and when you're on tour and you're on stage, is that your brother, is that Shannon, or when you're working on a film,
听着，我懂，你饿了。对不起。所以，所以，所以，但我真正想了解的是，当你这么说的时候，当你觉得你不想让任何人失望、你不想让任何人扫兴，当你巡演登台时，那是为了你弟弟香农，还是当你拍电影时，
is that all the people around you, is that your brother, is that Shannon, when you're working on a film, is that all the people around you, is that the people at home, is that an idea, sort of a general idea of letting people down, like is that something you've always had? No, I think it's all of the above. And you know, I don't carry that with me as a burden, I kind of, for me, that's fuel for the fire. And you know, I don't know, maybe you guys feel this way too,
那是为了你周围所有人，那是为了你弟弟香农，当你拍电影时，那是为了你周围所有人，那是为了家里的人，还是为了某种理念——那种不让别人失望的普遍理念——这就像是你一直以来都有的心态吗？不，我觉得以上种种皆有。而且你知道，我并不把这当成一种负担，对我来说，这是火焰的燃料。你知道，我不知道，也许你们也有同感，
but when I'm on set, I feel like it's my job to try and be one of the hardest working people on the set. It's my job to absolutely deliver every single time that I come to set. Of course you're gonna fail, but that's the goal. To be over-prepared, to know my lines, to know your lines, to have a thousand ideas to bring to the table, and to really just die for it.
但当我在片场时，我觉得我的工作就是努力成为片场最刻苦工作的人之一。我的工作就是在每次来到片场时都绝对做到最好。你当然会失败，但这才是目标。要过度准备，熟悉我的台词，熟悉你的台词，带上一千个点子供大家讨论，并且真正为之拼命。
And to also try to be the kindest person that I can be every single day, and to be supportive and be a good partner. Like those are the simple things that kind of continue to get me through it. But when you're as prepared as you are, like you just described, that eliminates fear. That's true.
同时还要努力成为每天所能成为的最善良的人，给予支持，做一个好的搭档。这些就是一直支撑我度过难关的简单事情。但当你像你刚才描述的那样做足了准备时，这就消除了恐惧。确实如此。
Yeah, that's very well said. I think preparation is definitely a confidence builder. And sometimes if I haven't been on tour for a long time, I'm like, and we have a huge show and there's a ton of people out there and I'm like, oh my God, what do I do? And then you get out there and you just, your body remembers. All of this sounds like a really, really, really good work ethic and a deep sense of discipline and focus.
是的，这话讲得真好。我认为准备绝对是自信的基石。有时如果我很久没有去巡演了，我会想，而且我们有一场盛大的演出，台下有成吨的人，我会想：“天哪，我该怎么办？”然后你走上台，你的身体自然就记起来了。所有这一切听起来都像是非常非常优秀的职业道德，以及深刻的纪律感和专注力。
Did you have that as a young kid? Was that something that your mom taught you? Did you discover it in school? Or did you just kinda come out of the box with it? My mom. My mom was and is a great teacher. In a large part, I dedicated my Oscar speech to my mother and I had an opportunity.
你小时候就这样吗？这是你妈妈教你的吗？你是在学校里发现这一点的？还是你天生就自带这种特质？我妈妈。我妈妈过去是、现在也是一位伟大的老师。很大程度上，我把奥斯卡获奖感言献给了我母亲，我当时有这样一个机会。
I always think, like, by the way, I never thought that I would win a single award in my entire life. Those are the people that went as much deserved. Never, never, never, never, never would happen to me. Never, ever. So I was like, well, I'm going to use this as an opportunity to really thank the people in my life that have inspired and encouraged me. And first and foremost,
我总觉得，顺便说一句，我从来没想过自己这辈子能赢得哪怕一个奖项。那些得奖的人才是真正实至名归的。绝无可能，绝无可能，绝无可能，这绝对不会发生在我身上。绝对不会。所以我想，好吧，我要利用这个机会，好好感谢生活中那些曾启发和鼓励过我的人。首先也是最重要的人，
that's my mom and my mom, she was a single mom. We grew up really poor and you know, like food stamp. I was born in Louisiana as was my brother and you know, my mother was high school dropout, but put herself back through school with two kids, single mom, and got a nursing degree. And really worked and fought really hard to make a better life for herself and her kids. And you watched that, you observed that.
那就是我妈妈。我妈妈，她是个单亲妈妈。我们小时候真的很穷，你知道的，领过食品券。我和我弟弟都是在路易斯安那州出生的，你知道，我母亲高中都没毕业，但作为单亲妈妈，她带着两个孩子重新回到学校深造，拿到了护理学位。她真的付出了努力，拼命工作，为自己和孩子们创造更好的生活。你看着这一切，你观察到了这一点。
And I saw that. And I saw her do, if there was a shift that came up, she would take that. I saw her do those extra, I don't know, but they were these really long shifts, at least 12 hours. And then she would do night shifts, and I saw her work, and I saw her dedication, and I watched her educate herself. I watched her, and it taught me a lot. And she was always very creative and really kind of broke the mold in her family.
我看到了。我看到她这么做，如果有临时班要加，她就会接下来。我看到她做那些额外的——我不知道，但那些都是非常漫长的班，至少12个小时。然后她还要上夜班，我看到她工作，看到她的奉献精神，我看着她自我教育。我看着这一切，这教会了我很多。而且她一直很有创造力，在她的家族里真正打破了常规。
So that was a big lesson for me. All right, so you leave Louisiana, where do you go from there? Where does the acting and the music bug start to bite you? Well, I was in art school and studying to be a painter. Oh, nice. Yeah. There's nothing you can't do. It was like, after a stint, kind of, it's funny, you know, I'm negotiating in my head
所以这对我是个很大的教训。好了，你离开了路易斯安那，接下来你去了哪里？表演和音乐的种子是什么时候开始在你心中萌芽的？嗯，我当时在艺术学校学习，想当一名画家。哦，不错。对。没有什么事是你做不到的。这就像是，经历了一段时间之后，挺逗的，你知道，我在脑海里做着权衡，
things that I want to talk about or not, because I actually don't talk about a lot of this stuff. We appreciate that, the fact that you're with... But it's something in my life too, I'm like, I'm negotiating as well, of like, you know, how do you, you know, what do you share, what do you not? As you guys have gotten older. What do you keep to yourself?
权衡哪些事情我想谈，哪些不想谈，因为其实很多这类事情我都不怎么聊。我们很感激这一点，事实上你愿意和……但这也是我生活中的一部分，我也在权衡，比如，你知道，你怎么做，你知道，什么该分享，什么不该分享？随着你们年纪越来越大。什么东西你会留给自己？
Yeah, and I've been less precious about it. And there's nothing fun about a safe interview, I've always felt, yeah. Yeah, and then, you know, you wanna share things, and you know, it's beautiful to share things. Well, can I say this, then maybe this will prime me a little bit. So I've been joking recently that I know,
是的，我对这种事的执念变小了。而且我一直觉得，一场四平八稳的访谈根本没有任何乐趣，对吧。对，然后，你知道，你会想要分享一些事情，而且，分享事情是一件很美妙的事。好吧，那我能这么说吗，也许这能让我稍微进入状态。所以我最近一直在开玩笑说，我知道，
I've been saying to people, for a guy who's a loud mouth, know it all, me, I know embarrassingly little about art. And it's been like this blind spot that I've had my whole life. And I kind of started to own it recently. And from the moment I started saying that, I've started meeting all these artists, painters.
我经常对别人说，作为一个大嘴巴、自以为无所不知的人，我自己对艺术的了解却少得让人尴尬。这就像是我一辈子以来的盲区。我最近开始坦然承认这一点。而从我开始这么说的那一刻起，我就开始遇到所有这些艺术家、画家。
I've met three new painters in the last 24 hours alone who have revealed to me, oh, I'm a painter. And so I've been reading this book about the cooning I'm boring these guys about, but I'm reading this book about, and it's kind of like now, because I've been putting it out there, it's been coming. And I said to Alessandro, my partner this morning,
光是在过去的24小时里，我就遇到了三位新画家，他们向我透露，哦，我是一名画家。所以，我一直在读这本关于德·库宁的书，我一直在跟这些人唠叨，但我正在读这本书，而且现在感觉就像是，因为我把它说出来了，它就找上门来了。我今天早上对我的合伙人亚历山德罗说，
we rode our bikes down to the beach. I'm out here in Long Island. I rode my bike down to the beach and I said, I can't believe I'm saying this. I think I'm gonna start painting. Yeah, I get it. I love that. I love that.
我们骑着自行车去了海滩。我在长岛这边。我骑着自行车去了海滩，我说，我真不敢相信我会这么说。我想我要开始画画了。是的，我懂。我太喜欢这个了。我太喜欢了。
And I'm embarrassed because I feel like a fucking cliche. I get it. And I'm like, I don't give a shit. I love it. I think it's great. I fucking feel it. And I don't know anything, I really don't. I'm a fucking novice of novices.
而且我很尴尬，因为我觉得自己像个他妈的陈词滥调。我懂。但我想，我他妈才不在乎呢。我太喜欢了。我觉得这太棒了。我他妈能感觉得到。我什么都不懂，真的什么都不懂。我他妈就是新手中的新手。
But I feel really connected to it. That's awesome. Yeah, that's beautiful. Do you still do it, Jared? You know, I don't paint that much. I draw sometimes and I put a lot of my creative energy. And by the way, I think that's one of the important things in life is to keep learning, to keep,
但我对它有一种真正的连接感。太棒了。是的，太美妙了。你现在还画画吗，杰瑞德？你知道的，我画得不多。我有时画画，而且我投入了大量的创作能量。顺便说一句，我认为生活中的重要事情之一就是不断学习，不断，
I always say I love to be the dumbest guy in the room. And that's a fascinating room to be in and do a lot of stuff. Yeah, and fortunately I have the opportunity to do that quite a bit. But no, I think it's great to continue to learn to do new things and just to be a beginner again. Do you get knee deep in the artwork
我总是说我喜欢做房间里最蠢的人。这是一个奇妙的房间，能在里面做很多事情。是的，幸运的是我有很多这样的机会。但是不，我认为继续学习做新事物并再次成为一个初学者是很棒的。你会深入研究艺术品吗？
for the albums and stuff like that? Probably in artwork. Too much, probably, yeah. I'm the guy that makes like a thousand different album covers. But album artwork has always consistently been like, to me, really cool, or concert t-shirt designs and all that.
为了专辑之类的东西？大概在艺术品方面。可能太多了，是的。我就是那种会做一千种不同专辑封面的人。但专辑封面对我来说一直都是非常酷的东西，或者说演唱会T恤设计等等。
I'm a big radiohead freak. I'm doing that every three days. We're doing a new t-shirt design. And it's something that's a consistent thing. I love that. But with the album artwork, I did a thousand different covers and then you know what I did? I did this little art project where I was taking a photo
我是个超级电台司令（Radiohead）狂热粉。我每三天就在做这个。我们在做一个新的T恤设计。这是一件持续在做的事情。我太喜欢了。但是关于专辑封面，我做了一千种不同的封面，然后你知道我做了什么吗？我做了这样一个小型艺术项目，我每天都在拍一张照片。
of the sky every day, right? And you know, after about three months it gets really annoying, by the way, I'll tell you. I'd say to my assistant, I'd be like, can you just grab that photo today? It wasn't from the same place every day, right? No, but it's anywhere you are, it's just like, oh I forgot, and then you try to make up for it. But anyway, I had hundreds of photos of these skies
拍天空的照片，对吧？你知道的，大约三个月后，这会变得非常烦人，顺便说一句，我告诉你。我会对我的助理说，你可以把今天的照片拿来吗？它不是每天都在同一个地方拍的，对吧？不，但无论你在哪里，它就像是，哦我忘了，然后你试着去弥补。总之，我有几百张这些天空的照片。
and I thought, oh, maybe that's an album cover. So I did 10 different album covers, just basically cell phone pictures of the sky and that ended up being kind of the basis of our artwork for our new album. That's cool. Which is called It's the End of the World, but It's a Beautiful Day. So it ended up being a nice. But by the way, Sean, for our new album. That's cool. Which is called, It's the End of the World, but It's a Beautiful Day.
我想，哦，也许那是个专辑封面。所以我做了10个不同的专辑封面，基本上就是手机拍的天空照片，结果这成了我们新专辑艺术设计的基础。这很酷。专辑名叫《世界末日，但今天是个好日子》（It's the End of the World, but It's a Beautiful Day）。所以这最终是一次不错的体验。但顺便说一句，肖恩，为了我们的新专辑。这很酷。它的名字叫《世界末日，但今天是个好日子》。
So it ended up being a nice experience. But by the way, Sean, you gotta cue. Didn't you have hundreds of photos of these guys? No, he said skies. He said skies. Got it. He took hundreds of skies. Got it.
所以这最终是一次不错的体验。但顺便说一句，肖恩，你得给个提示。你不是有数百张这些家伙的照片吗？不，他说的是天空。他说的是天空。明白了。他拍了成百上千的天空。明白了。
I was taking hundreds of photos of them. Sorry. And then I'd hear a knock on my door from the place. Sorry, my hearing is so bad. My hearing is so bad. Jared, you reminded me of like, Oh, mine was of the same guy. You remind me of this really cool documentary
我一直在拍成百上千张它们的照片。对不起。然后我会听到有人敲我的门。抱歉，我的听力太差了。我的听力太差了。杰瑞德，你让我想起了，哦，我的是同一个家伙。你让我想起了这个非常酷的纪录片。
I read about you directed where you simultaneously filmed a day in the life of the 50 different states. Is that, am I describing it? I did something called The Day in the Life of America. Our album, our previous album in 2018 was called America. And it was that time when the world was kinda getting a little wild. It still hasn't recovered, I think.
我读过关于你导演的那部，你同时拍摄了50个不同州一天的生活。是这样吗，我是在描述这个吗？我做了一部叫《美国的一天》（A Day in the Life of America）的作品。我们的专辑，2018年的上一张专辑叫《美国》。那是世界变得有点疯狂的时期。我想它现在还没有恢复。
I was gonna say. Specifically America. But anyway, yeah, I was inspired by a book that I had when I was a kid, National Geographic, where they took photos in every state in a single day. So we sent camera crews, we actually had 92 crews all over the country. What?
我正要说呢。特指美国。不过话说回来，是的，我受到了一本书的启发，那是我小时候有的，国家地理杂志，他们在单日内在每个州都拍了照片。所以我们派出了摄像团队，我们在全国各地实际上有92个摄制组。什么？
In every state, in Puerto Rico, as well in Alaska. And we made this documentary about a kind of one day, and it was fascinating. We had the birth of a child, we had someone pass away on camera. I mean, it was like, it was a really, we saw it all. And it was on 4th of July, so we had all the fireworks. Oh, no way, that's cool. How do you like that?
在每个州，在波多黎各，也在阿拉斯加。我们拍了这部关于某一天的纪录片，非常迷人。我们拍摄了一个孩子的诞生，我们在镜头前看到有人离世。我的意思是，这就像，这是一个真正的，我们看到了这一切。而且那天是7月4日，所以我们拍到了所有的烟花。哦，不会吧，太酷了。你觉得怎么样？
How do you like directing and then directing narrative versus documentary? I know you do a lot of producing too. Are those areas that you're looking to challenge yourself on as well? Well, I started off in, I was a painter in art school. Are those areas that you're looking to challenge yourself on as well? I was a painter in art school, and then I took photography class and I got obsessed. I'd be in the dark room.
你觉得导演工作怎么样，还有导演叙事片与纪录片的对比？我知道你也做了很多制片工作。这些也是你想要挑战自己的领域吗？嗯，我一开始是，我在艺术学校时是个画家。这些也是你想要挑战自己的领域吗？我在艺术学校时是个画家，然后我上了摄影课，就着迷了。我会待在暗室里。
I don't know if you guys have ever done that, but that's a really fun thing to do, to shoot and develop your... Go ahead, Will, that's a great tee up for you, for Sean, in a dark room? No, nothing yet? Hundreds of these guys in a dark room, I keep coming back. You work on it and come back and interrupt them. But wait, wait, wait, Chair, I want to talk, I want to know about you becoming a painter. Like when, what was that? Well, I grew up around, my mom was, you know,
我不知道你们有没有做过那个，但那真的是一件很有趣的事，拍摄并冲洗你的……说吧，威尔，这对你来说是个很好的铺垫，为了肖恩，在暗室里？不，还没什么？在暗室里有成百上千的这些家伙，我一直在回过头来。你处理一下然后回来打断他们。但是等等，等等，等等，杰瑞德，我想谈谈，我想了解你成为画家的事。就像什么时候，那是什么时候？嗯，我是伴随着，我妈妈是，你知道，
I had a hippie mom, and she had a lot of really creative friends. And I always thought that I would either be a painter, I don't know. My dad was a painter and a photographer, for real. Oh wow. Yeah. I love both those things.
我有一个嬉皮士妈妈，她有很多真的很有创意的朋。我一直以为我要么会成为一个画家，我不知道。我爸爸是个画家兼摄影师，真的。哦，哇。是的。我热爱这两件事。
He was, really. It's awesome. My mom is a great photographer, and I grew up around seeing her photos, and she taught me a lot about photography when I was a kid. So one day I was, this school had like a performing arts section to it. I would go over and watch the actors and I always thought, man, that is terrifying. They are so brave, what they're doing running around out there on stage.
他真的是。太棒了。我妈妈是个伟大的摄影师，我是看着她的照片长大的，我小时候她教了我很多关于摄影的知识。所以有一天我在，这所学校有一个表演艺术部门。我会过去看演员们表演，我总是想，天哪，太可怕了。他们太勇敢了，他们在舞台上跑来跑去做的那些事。
And I didn't understand any of it. I was like, this is just insane. But I asked the school, I started taking a film class. Like a film as a kind of, you know, fine art, not like film as cinema, as Hollywood movies. So I fell in love with that and you know, just like film history, you'd watch classics? No, they had like bolex cameras that you'd rent and you'd shoot. Filmmaking.
我完全不懂。我想，这简直太疯狂了。但我问学校，我开始上一门电影课。就像电影作为一种，你知道的，纯艺术，不是作为电影院的那种电影，作为好莱坞电影。所以我爱上了那个，你知道的，就像电影史，你会看经典作品？不，他们有那种你可以租来拍摄的波莱士（Bolex）摄像机。电影制作。
Yeah, so you'd shoot film, black and white film, and then you'd have to send it away to get developed and we would edit using razor blades and tape. There wasn't a single computer. I remember the first computer that came into that art school was a Macintosh and nobody used it. You know, it just sat in the corner. The Apple II.
是的，所以你会拍胶片，黑白胶片，然后你必须把它寄出去冲洗，我们用剃须刀片和胶带进行剪辑。连一台电脑都没有。我记得进入那所艺术学校的第一台电脑是麦金塔（Macintosh），而且没有人用它。你知道的，它就放在角落里。Apple II。
Yeah. Yeah, so anyway, I was studying painting. I fell in love with photography. I took a film class. I switched my major to film. And then I asked the school to create a class for directors about acting. And I bothered them. I went there maybe 200 times,
对。对，总之，我当时在学画画。我爱上了摄影。我选了一门电影课。我把专业转成了电影。然后我要求学校为导演开设一门关于表演的课。我一直烦他们。我去了大概200次，
and the lady kind of looked at me and frustrated one day and says, you know what? I admire your persistence. And she like, you know, she just like. What does that mean, directors for acting? Acting for directors, sorry. Acting for directors, gotcha. Acting for directors.
那位女士看了我一眼，有一天显得很沮丧，说，你知道吗？我钦佩你的执着。她就像是，你知道的，她就这样。这是什么意思，导演学表演？演员表演给导演看，抱歉。演员表演给导演看，明白了。演员表演给导演看。
So I thought like, okay, I'm studying film, even though it was a kind of arty farty fine art film, but we should understand what acting is. But I had this little secret, I was, I thought, this is interesting. Yeah, and it got more attention in your mind than directing. Well, they created the class after I bugged them, and there got more attention in your mind than directing. Well, they created the class after I bugged them
所以我想，好吧，我在学电影，尽管那是一种艺术气息很浓的纯艺术电影，但我们应该了解表演是什么。但我有个小秘密，我在想，这很有趣。是的，在你的心目中，它比导演获得了更多的关注吗？嗯，在我烦了他们之后，他们开设了这门课，在你的心目中，它比导演获得了更多的关注吗？在我烦了他们之后，他们开设了这门课，
and there was like, I don't know, maybe four or five people we were doing, you know, acting like animals and doing all these experiments. And, you know, I don't know how much I learned in that class, but shortly after that, I had dropped out of college. I ended up in California. To pursue acting. Music and acting, yeah.
大概有四、五个人吧，我们在做，你知道的，像动物一样表演，做所有这些实验。而且，你知道的，我不知道我在那节课学到了多少东西，但没过多久，我就从大学退学了。我最终来到了加州。为了追求表演。音乐和表演，是的。
Yeah, that's awesome, unbelievable. Yeah, that's my life story. It's really cool how you've been able to keep, but it's just like, as I said, it's sort of in my crappy intro, that you've been incredibly successful in both of these careers, like enormously successful, yet you've managed to not lean in and take the bait
是的，太棒了，难以置信。是的，这就是我的人生故事。真的很酷，你是如何保持的，但就像我说的，就像我刚才那个糟糕的开场白里说的，你在这两个职业中都取得了难以置信的成功，简直是巨大的成功，然而你却设法没有顺应潮流去吞下诱饵，
and eat the junk food that propels that kind of success and notoriety into celebratiness, if that's a word. It's not. It's just not. Well, we all fail a lot, right? I mean, I always say I fail more than anybody that I know. I fail all the time. Well, you're just getting to know me.
去吃那些将那种成功和声誉推向名人效应（如果这是一个词的话）的垃圾食品。这不是。它根本不是。嗯，我们都经历过很多失败，对吧？我的意思是，我总是说我比我认识的任何人都失败得多。我一直在失败。嗯，你才刚刚开始了解我。
Yeah. Yeah, but I mean, like, but to Jason's point, it's like you don't get sucked into that. Is that a conscious decision? Do you say no to a lot of things because you like to stay private? Do you say no because you don't wanna deal with it? I mean. Well. You say no because you don't want to deal with it. I mean, well...
是的。是的，但我的意思是，就像，但顺着杰森的观点，这就像你没有被卷入其中。这是一个有意识的决定吗？你对很多事情说不，因为你喜欢保持低调？你拒绝是因为你不想去应付那些吗？我的意思是。嗯。你拒绝是因为你不想去应付那些吗？我的意思是，嗯……
It's just not you. Yeah, I mean, I'm actually an introvert. Yeah, me too. Which is bizarre because of my choices out there. As far as work goes. Yeah, because you're a movie star and you're in a rock band, it doesn't seem like a perfect spot for an introvert to live. You know what I mean?
这根本不是你的风格。是的，我的意思是，我其实是个内向的人。是的，我也是。这真奇怪，鉴于我在聚光灯下的选择。就工作而言。是的，因为你是个电影明星，又在一个摇滚乐队里，这看起来不像是内向者生活的完美场所。你知道我的意思吗？
Yeah, it's a strange thing. But you know, when I'm done with the show, I literally leave the show. Yeah, I go to the hotel room, get food and, you know, turn on Netflix and that's it. Yeah, yeah. Dunsel Washington. Yeah, wow. We'll be right back.
是的，这很奇怪。但你知道的，当我演出结束时，我真的是直接离开演出现场。是的，我回酒店房间，弄点吃的，然后，你知道的，打开奈飞（Netflix），就这样。是的，是的。丹泽尔·华盛顿（Denzel Washington）。是的，哇。我们马上回来。
And back to the show. What is, what do you, aside from that sort of that decompression routine of just kind of getting quiet, getting by yourself, watching little TV, is there anything else that you can really rely on that gets you to your small self? And is it reading?
欢迎回到节目中。除了那种减压的常规做法——比如让自己安静下来，独处一会儿，看一点电视——还有什么事是你真正可以依赖，能让你回归自我、找回那个小小的自己的吗？是读书吗？
Is there a video game that you play or whatever, an app on the phone? Or like, Willie and I, we play like fricking word games on the phone. And like, golf sometimes gets us quiet. Yeah, for me I have work. I love to work. That's my favorite thing in the world to do.
有什么你玩的电子游戏，或者别的什么，手机上的应用？或者像威尔和我，我们在手机上玩那种烦人的文字游戏。而且，有时候打高尔夫能让我们安静下来。是的，对我来说我有工作。我热爱工作。这是我世界上最喜欢做的事情。
I love to work, work, and work some more. And if I have some time, I like to climb. And then I like to free dive, which I just started a couple of years ago. I want to talk about that. Free dive off of a cliff to the ocean. Is that like the big blue, like that Luc Besson film? Yeah, Le Grand Bleu. Le free dive off the big blue like that look this off. Yeah, look on blue Yeah, the crumble is if say incredible
我喜欢工作、工作、再多工作一点。如果我有时间，我喜欢攀岩。然后我喜欢自由潜水，这是我几年前刚开始的。我想聊聊这个。从悬崖自由潜水到海洋里。那就像《碧海蓝天》（The Big Blue）那样吗，吕克·贝松（Luc Besson）的那部电影？是的，Le Grand Bleu。自由潜水去大蓝洞就像那样看看这个。耶，看看蓝色，是的，蛋糕是如果说不可思议的
Where I take one to know I see my mistress I And then... And then it's like, coucou! Coucou! So this is dining... Every French person, every French person that comes in the room sort of like saying hi and they'll go, coucou! Why is that? I had this woman who I worked with
我带一去知道我看到我的情妇我然后……然后就像是，布谷！布谷！所以这就是在吃饭……每一个法国人，每一个走进房间的法国人都有点像是在打招呼，然后他们会说，布谷！这是为什么？我曾和一个女人共事，
and I was living in the south of France and I could hear her from there and go, coucou! What the fuck? Why coucou? Oh my God, Stop with all that. You're annoying me. Why do they say cuckoo? It's like the Englishman with the pip pip, right?
当时我住在法国南部，我能听到她从那里传来，然后说，布谷！搞什么鬼？为什么是布谷？天哪，别搞那些了。你烦死我了。为什么他们说布谷？就像英国人说“皮普皮普”（pip pip）一样，对吧？
It's almost like a you-hoo, but it's like... But wait, so this is diving without oxygen? Yeah, it's not... A lot of people, when you say free dive, a lot of people think jumping off a cliff. Oh, okay. Like me. Yeah, it's not a lot of people when you say free dive a lot of people think jumping off a cliffs Okay, like me it's not you know free diving is either people focus on depth People focus on time
这有点像“喂——呼”（you-hoo），但它就像是……但是等等，所以这是不带氧气瓶的潜水？是的，不是……很多人，当你说自由潜水时，很多人以为是从悬崖上跳下去。哦，好吧。像我一样。是的，不是，很多人当你说自由潜水时，很多人以为是从悬崖上跳下去。好吧，像我一样。不是，你知道的，自由潜水要么是人们关注深度，人们关注时间。
There's static diving. There's free diving. What's the kind of what kind of depths are we talking about right now? I like to dive through caves. That's my But not with a tank right with no there's no way out will my God. I mean, that's right there. But not with a tank. Right, so there's no way out. Well, there's no. But again, I'm a beginner. I'm a beginner rock climber. I'm a beginner free diver.
有静态潜水。有自由潜水。我们现在谈论的是什么深度的？我喜欢穿梭于洞穴。那是我的——但不是带着氧气罐，对吧，没有，绝对没有出路，威尔，我的天哪。我的意思是，就在那里。但不是带着氧气罐。对，所以没有出路。嗯，没有。但话说回来，我是个初学者。我是个初学攀岩者。我是个初学者自由潜水员。
I am definitely an amateur. Well, your beginning ass just went up the Empire State Building in your diving cave. So you're doing okay. I'm doing okay, I'm alive. How long can you stay under? You can stay under. Let me guess, let me guess, let me guess.
我绝对是个业余爱好者。好吧，你这个初学者竟然带着你的潜水装备爬上了帝国大厦。所以你做得挺好。我做得挺好，我还活着。你能呆在水下多久？你可以呆在水下。让我猜猜，让我猜猜，让我猜猜。
I don't really go for time. Okay, but let me guess how long you can hold your breath. And I know this oversimplifies things, it dumbs it down for us idiots. I'll bet that you can get to three minutes pretty easily. Will, Sean, do you have any guesses? I was just thinking about how long I can stay under propofol, like an hour.
我其实并不追求时间。好吧，但让我猜猜你能屏住呼吸多久。我知道这把事情过分简单化了，把这事对我们这些白痴来说简化了。我敢打赌你很容易就能达到三分钟。威尔，肖恩，你们有什么猜测吗？我刚才在想我能在丙泊酚（propofol）麻醉下呆多久，大概一个小时。
Or when you choke yourself out, how long can you stay before it? When I get my belt around the top of the door, Jim, when I'm trying to squeeze one out. I'm gonna say, what's the record? Because I saw something like 16 minutes. I'm gonna say three and a half minutes, Jared. Jason said three.
或者当你把自己勒住时，在它之前你能坚持多久？当我把皮带缠在门顶上时，吉姆，当我正试图挤出一个屁的时候。我要说，纪录是多少？因为我看到过类似16分钟的报道。我要说三分钟半，杰瑞德。杰森说三分钟。
I'm gonna say four. I'll say four. a half minutes, Jared. Jason said three, I'm gonna say four. I'll say four. Jared? Absolutely, yeah. Three minutes for sure, four minutes for sure. No way! So it goes longer. Oh, people go a lot longer.
我要说四分钟。我说是四分钟半，杰瑞德。杰森说三，我要说四。我说是四。杰瑞德？绝对的，是的。三分钟肯定行，四分钟肯定行。不会吧！所以时间更长。哦，人们能待更久。
That's not a lot for, that's not, it's not impressive at all in the world of freediving. That is a beginner. Now are there, okay, so where are the great caves? In Majorca, Sardinia, Corsica, all the beautiful places. I just was in Greece, there was some good stuff there. But I focus on depth and I focus on caves. The deepest I've gone is 108 feet.
在自由潜水界，这不算什么，这不算，一点也不让人印象深刻。那只是初学者。那么，好吧，伟大的洞穴都在哪里？在马略卡岛、撒丁岛、科西嘉岛，所有这些美丽的地方。我刚刚去了希腊，那里有一些好东西。但我专注于深度，我专注于洞穴。我下潜的最深记录是108英尺。
Jesus Christ. Well, you need 10 minutes to re-acclimate or whatever as you come back up, don't you? No, you don't have to. No. That's only with scuba diving. Yeah. Wow. Okay. So you just use your lungs and that's it. He doesn't know anything. Jared, Jared, why don't you just like take up reading man or something?
天哪。好吧，当你上来时，你需要10分钟来重新适应环境什么的，对吧？不，你不需要。不。那是水肺潜水才有的。耶。哇。好吧。所以你只需要用你的肺，就这样。他什么都不知道。杰瑞德，杰瑞德，你为什么不干脆去读读书或者别的什么呢？
Why are you jumping off cliffs or swimming in the cliffs. Why don't you just get involved with the crown? There's a bunch of seasons you can watch. Um. You know, there are a lot of shows I've never seen that I've been waiting to see. What do you wanna see? What do you wanna see that you feel like you missed out?
你为什么要在悬崖上跳来跳去或者在悬崖里游泳？你为什么不干脆看看《王冠》（The Crown）呢？有很多季你可以看。嗯。你知道的，有很多我从未看过的节目，我一直等着看。你想看什么？你觉得你错过了什么，想看什么？
What was the Game of Thrones I never saw? I never saw that. I never saw the first season. By the way, I never saw The Simpsons. I never saw Family Guy. I never saw South Park. But I did see Ozark, and I would annoyingly email Jason often
我从没看过的是哪个？《权力的游戏》（Game of Thrones）我从来没看过。我从来没看过。我连第一季都没看过。顺便说一句，我从没看过《辛普森一家》（The Simpsons）。我从没看过《恶搞之家》（Family Guy）。我从没看过《南方公园》（South Park）。但我看过《黑钱胜地》（Ozark），而且我会烦人地经常给杰森发邮件，
with thoughts on the plot developments and characters and how much I love the show and just kind of fawning with Jason. But when you give me notes, I'd remind him we're locked. Picture's locked, so just keep it to compliments. I have a question though for all three of you because you're all wonderfully sober. But do you think you do these climbers, these diving, like all these things because they take the place,
表达我对剧情发展和角色的看法，以及我有多么喜欢这部剧，只是有点在奉承杰森。但当你给我提意见时，我会提醒他我们已经定稿了。画面已经剪辑定型了，所以还是多说点赞美的话吧。不过我有一个问题要问你们三位，因为你们都戒酒了而且状态很好。但你觉得你们做这些攀岩、潜水之类的事情，是因为它们能取代某种刺激，就像毒品带来的刺激吗？
it's a rush that takes the place of a drug? No, I don't think so. I find them to be very peaceful when I climb and when I dive. You have to remain peaceful. If you're a hundred feet under the water, sometimes what's wild is you do have a conversation about death with yourself, because it's scary sometimes.
不，我不这么认为。我发现当我攀岩和潜水时，它们非常平静。你必须保持平静。如果你在水下一百英尺，有时疯狂的是你会和自己进行关于死亡的对话，因为有时真的很吓人。
And then you have these moments of peace that are just outstanding. It's almost like drugs sometimes, or alcohol, at least for me, was sort of the fun of kind of escaping from being inside myself and kind of adding a little of this and adding a little of that and going to sort of a different version of myself. Whereas it sounds like your experience is the opposite arrow and it's just a real internal thing. Well, it compels you into the moment.
然后你会有那些非常出色的平静时刻。这几乎有时有点像毒品或酒精，至少对我自己而言，那种乐趣在于逃离内心的自我，加一点这个，加一点那个，然后变成自己的另一种版本。然而听起来你的经历恰恰相反，亚罗，这只是一种真正的内在体验。嗯，它迫使你专注于当下。
Being on the stage, being underwater, climbing a rock, that you have to be present. You don't have a choice. You have to be so present. And you're not thinking about your phone, you're not thinking about your job, your girlfriend, your boyfriend, you're not thinking about any of that.
站在舞台上，在水下，攀登岩石，你必须在场。你别无选择。你必须如此全神贯注。你不会去想你的手机，你不会去想你的工作，你的女朋友，你的男朋友，你什么都不会去想。
You're thinking about what's right in front of you. So it's incredibly simple and primal, I think, in some ways. Yeah, I should note that I don't think I've been wonderfully sober. I think I've had a few missteps over the years, definitely. For me, it's been a process. No, of course it's okay. That's part of it.
你只想着眼前的事情。所以在某种程度上，我认为这是极其简单和原始的。是的，我应该指出，我不认为我一直都保持着清醒和理智。我想这些年来我经历过几次失误，绝对的。对我来说，这是一个过程。不，当然可以。这也是其中的一部分。
It's been a process for me, or as we say in Canada, a process. But you get to know yourself a little bit better, and I do find those things. It's a combination of what Jared said and what Jason said, which is for me is about being present and being okay with being present and trying to accept where I am. And it's all about powerlessness and all that sort of stuff and realizing it and being,
对我来说，这是一个过程，或者正如我们在加拿大所说，一个“过程”（process，发音不同）。但你会更好地了解自己一点，我确实发现了这些事情。这是杰瑞德所说和杰森所说的结合，对我来说，这就是关于专注于当下，并接受当下的状态，试着接受我所在的位置。这一切都关于无能为力以及诸如此类的事情，去意识到这一点，并且存在着，
and realizing where you are and where you sit in the world. I don't know about you guys, I've thought, and not to a crazy degree, but I've been thinking a lot more about my mortality in the last few years. We're on the back side. Yeah, and I think about, I was saying last night, Jared, you might have heard me waxing on
去意识到你在哪里以及你在世界上的位置。我不知道你们怎么样，我想过，虽然没有到疯狂的程度，但在过去的几年里，我更多地思考了我的必死性。我们已经走过了下坡路。是的，而且我想着，我昨晚说过，杰瑞德，你可能听到我滔滔不绝地讲了，
about this memorial I went to, and I was thinking about, we all are here for this one visit. We're not making another trip. We got five minutes left. We're on this, and so it better be good. And we better be happy. And we're all just trying to figure out
关于我去参加的那个追悼会，我在想，我们所有人来这里都只有这么一趟。我们不会再来第二次了。我们只剩下五分钟了。我们就在这趟旅程中，所以最好过得精彩。而且我们最好快乐。我们所有人都在试图弄清楚，
how to get through it the best way. I think I'm coming back. I wanna come back as Jared. I know, Jared, it would be pretty good. But wait, Jared, I have two questions really fast. One is about Tron, because I'm a huge fan of the franchise. Yeah, he's a big sci-fi fan. Are you as well, Jared, is that what brought you to this?
如何以最好的方式度过它。我想我会回来的。我想作为杰瑞德回来。我知道，杰瑞德，那会相当不错。但是等等，杰瑞德，我有两个非常快的问题。一个是关于《创：战纪》（Tron），因为我是这个系列的超级粉丝。是的，他是个铁杆科幻迷。你也是吗，杰瑞德，这就是你加入这部电影的原因吗？
Super fan. Oh, wow, yeah. Super, super, super, super fan. Tron and Blade Runner were the two movies that really changed my life as a kid. And now you've been in both. Yeah, bizarre. So I'm living in my simulation over here for sure. Yeah, right.
超级粉丝。哦，哇，是的。超级，超级，超级，超级粉丝。《创：战纪》和《银翼杀手》（Blade Runner）是我小时候真正改变我人生的两部电影。而现在你两部都演了。是的，太诡异了。所以我绝对生活在我的模拟世界里。是的，对吧。
What can you tell us about Tron without revealing? We've been developing it for almost 10 years. Yeah, wow. And it's called Tron Aries. Is it picked up right where the last one left off or no? In a way, yeah, it does. Yeah. Yeah, it does. So, yeah, I'm super excited.
关于《创：战纪》，在不剧透的情况下你能告诉我们什么？我们开发它已经将近10年了。是的，哇。它叫《创：战纪：战神》（Tron: Ares）。它紧接着上一部结束的地方开始，还是没有？在某种程度上，是的，它确实。是的。是的，它确实。所以，是的，我超级兴奋。
And for me, like, one of the highlights was working with Jeff Bridges. I was just gonna say, any conversations with him on this one? Oh, God, he's just the best. Oh my God. I had one take where I had to, literally, I had to say cut, and they were like, what's wrong?
对我来说，比如，亮点之一就是与杰夫·布里吉斯（Jeff Bridges）合作。我正要说呢，在这部电影里跟他有过什么对话吗？哦，天哪，他简直是太棒了。哦，天哪。我拍过一个镜头，我 literalmente（字面意义上）不得不喊“咔”，然后他们问，怎么了？
Some of the guys, I was like, no, I just can't stop fucking smiling. Yeah. I love that guy. He's every, you know, it's money back guarantee. That motherfucker gives you everything you ever wanted. I have to do that all the time. That's the best.
有些家伙，我说，不，我就是他妈的笑得停不下来。是的。我太喜欢那家伙了。他就是每个，你知道的，如假包换。那个混蛋能给你你想要的一切。我不得不一直这么做。那是最好的。
But I think it's a great idea, and correct me if I'm wrong, isn't it where the Tron world gets transferred into the real world? Yeah, it's kind of the opposite. It's such a great idea. A little bit of the Terminator thing where that technology comes out into Earth.
但我认为这是一个很棒的主意，如果我错了请纠正我，是不是“创”的世界被传输到了现实世界中？是的，这有点相反。这是一个如此棒的主意。有点像《终结者》（Terminator）那种感觉，那种科技来到了地球上。
Oh, I like that. So smart. I like that. It puts it in context that we can kind of understand a little bit better maybe too. And then tell me, because I love, because I do a lot of theater, I love horror stories about live shows,
哦，我喜欢这样。太聪明了。我喜欢这样。它把它放在了一个我们可能也能更好地理解的语境中。然后告诉我，因为我喜欢，因为我经常做戏剧，我喜欢关于现场演出的恐怖故事，
and I know you do a lot of live shows. Was there any kind of crazy fan interaction, somebody rushed the stage? I do a lot of theater, I love horror stories about live shows, and I know you do a lot of live shows. Was there any kind of crazy fan interaction, somebody rushed the stage... Or every night. ...and completely lost the lyrics? Every night. We just played... I mean, the show and Cadot was incredible.
我知道你有很多现场演出的经验。有没有发生过什么疯狂的粉丝互动，有人冲上舞台？我经常做戏剧，我喜欢关于现场演出的恐怖故事，而且我知道你有很多现场演出的经验。有没有发生过什么疯狂的粉丝互动，有人冲上舞台……或者每晚都有。……然后完全忘词了？每晚都有。我们刚刚演出过……我的意思是，卡多（Cadot）的演出太不可思议了。
I mean, I fell in love with the entire audience. It was the craziest group of, like, shit-kicking, awesome Americans you've ever seen in your life. Absolutely insane. There were two people dressed like Beetlejuice. Yeah. You know? Another guy came.
我的意思是，我爱上了整个观众。那是我这辈子见过的最疯狂、最强悍、最了不起的美国人群体。绝对疯狂。有两个人打扮成甲壳虫汁（Beetlejuice）的模样。是的。你知道吗？另一个人来了。
I literally brought a guy on stage who was wearing a... Was it an American flag Speedo? Or was it just a... Yeah, an American flag Speedo. That's where it went, Will. Yeah. But let me tell you, I was just like, I was smiling the whole time.
我 literalmente（字面意义上）把一个穿着……是一个美国国旗Speedo泳裤的家伙请上了舞台吗？还是只是一条……是的，一条美国国旗Speedo泳裤。事情就是这样发展的，威尔。是的。但让我告诉你，我当时就是一直在笑。
I'm so grateful to be in front of these people and it was just incredible. So yeah, I've had the worst things happen and the most amazing. We, every night there's a catastrophe of some kind, like the mic goes out, you fall over. Right. Yeah.
我非常感激能站在这些人面前，这简直太不可思议了。所以，是的，我经历过最糟糕的事情和最奇妙的事情。我们，每天晚上都会发生某种灾难，比如麦克风没声音了，你摔倒了。对。是的。
You're playing all these major, major cities around the world, but I also see here, you got a couple of sold out shows coming up in Kazakhstan and Azerbaijan as well. What? Like, what's it like to tour? Wait, wait, wait, wait, what? Yeah, what's it like touring all these incredible corners
你在世界各地所有这些重大城市演出，但我也在这里看到，你接下来在哈萨克斯坦和阿塞拜疆也有几场门票售罄的演出。什么？就像，去巡演是什么感觉？等等，等等，等等，什么？是的，去地球上所有这些不可思议的角落巡演是什么感觉？
of the earth? Do you get out and and visit the local markets? And do you have time to plant for a day or two? Are you on to the next place always? Oh, absolutely. Even yesterday, I bought a bicycle a couple of days ago in Wisconsin. So we just take that out after the show,
你会出去参观当地的市场吗？你有时间计划呆上一两天地吗？还是总是马不停蹄地赶往下一个地方？哦，绝对的。就在昨天，几天前我在威斯康星州买了一辆自行车。所以我们只是在演出后、演出前、休息日把它拿出来，去探索那些城市。
before the show, on the day off, exploring the cities. And you just go explore, wow. Yeah, and this summer we were in Paris and in London, but we're also in Poland and we're in Italy and then we're headed to Sweden and to Kazakhstan. It's just incredible. Do you have a thing that is a constant in each one of these cities that you like to check out,
你只是去探索，哇。是的，今年夏天我们在巴黎和伦敦，但我们也在波兰和意大利，然后我们要去瑞典和哈萨克斯坦。这简直太不可思议了。在每一个这样的城市里，你有没有一件固定要做的事情，比如去看看那里的美食、博物馆、教堂或者别的什么，你只是、只是必须去看看他们版本的那些东西？
whether it be the food or the museums or the churches or the whatever that you just, just have to see their version of. No, I think, you know what I love to do when I'm on tour is I love to walk around the cities and kind of get away from the tourist areas and walk through like residential areas and see how people are living. I find that's a really good way to feel the culture
不，我认为，你知道我巡演时最喜欢做什么吗？我喜欢在城市里四处走走，避开旅游区，穿过住宅区，看看人们是如何生活的。我发现这是感受特定地方文化的真正好方法。
of a specific place. But the nice thing is it's not going to Poland for the first time, it's going for like the 10th time, the 15th time, because you find, you go back to that restaurant that you found seven times ago, you have a connection with the people and the place and the food. I wanna see you play.
但好的一面是，这不是第一次去波兰，而是第10次，第15次，因为你会发现，你回到了七次前发现的那家餐厅，你与那里的人、地方和食物建立了联系。我想看你演出。
Do you have any plans to come through LA anytime soon? Yeah, we didn, we are... We didn't put an LA date on this tour strategically. We actually are going to play a show next year, which is the 20th anniversary of our breakthrough album, which was called A Beautiful Lie. And we are going to play a show in Los Angeles to celebrate that.
你最近有什么计划来洛杉矶吗？是的，我们没有……我们在这次巡演中刻意没有安排洛杉矶的场次。我们实际上打算明年举办一场演出，那是我们突破性专辑发行20周年，那张专辑叫《美丽的谎言》（A Beautiful Lie）。我们将在洛杉矶举办一场演出以示庆祝。
Oh, that's great. That's next year. That's great. That's next year. And do you have a venue picked yet? I mean, are we making news? You know, we're making news, but it will either be a Hollywood Bowl or a forum or something like that. Oh, yeah. Great.
哦，那太棒了。那是明年。那太棒了。那是明年。你们选好场地了吗？我的意思是，我们在创造新闻吗？你知道的，我们在制造新闻，但它要么是好莱坞碗形剧场（Hollywood Bowl），要么是论坛体育馆（The Forum）之类的地方。哦，是的。太棒了。
I wanna see that. Jared, you've done so many things. Is there something you look at other people doing that you won't do that you're like, oh, I dive, I climb, I do movies, I play in front of millions of people? You know what? Yeah, theater.
我想看那个。杰瑞德，你做过太多事情了。有没有什么事是你看着别人在做，而你不会去做的，你会觉得，哦，我潜水、攀岩、拍电影、在数百万人面前表演？你知道吗？是的，戏剧。
Oh, really? Theater, theater. God, you'd be so good on stage. I'm gonna tell you why, and it's because I have so much respect for it, and I know how hard it is because I've had so many friends do it, that I just feel like I'd rather enjoy that
哦，真的吗？戏剧，戏剧。天哪，你在舞台上会表现得那么好。我来告诉你为什么，这是因为我对它怀有如此多的敬意，而且我知道它有多难，因为我有那么多朋友演过，我只是觉得我宁愿去欣赏它，
than be a part of it. I'm also on stage a lot as it is. So I don't have maybe the same itch that other people may have to kind of perform live because I'm getting pretty satisfied on that other side of it. But man, what a... I'm gonna make a prediction that you're gonna do
也不愿成为其中的一部分。况且我本来就已经经常在舞台上了。所以也许我没有其他人那种想要现场表演的强烈渴望，因为我在另一个领域已经得到了相当大的满足。但是天哪，多么……我做一个预测，你将在未来五年内，
a play in the next five years, and you're gonna win a Tony just like sweet Shawnee Hayes did. Yeah. I know, congrats on that, I heard about that. Will you not be surprised when I hit you with a text when you come to town next year? I'm gonna come rush the stage with my Speedo flag outfit. So it was you.
演一出戏剧，并且你会赢得一座托尼奖（Tony），就像可爱的肖妮·海斯（Shawnee Hayes）那样。是的。我知道，恭喜那个，我听说过。当你明年来到这个城镇时，我给你发短信，你可别惊讶。我要穿着我的美国国旗Speedo泳裤冲上舞台。原来是你。
Thank you. It was me. I would love for you to come. I would love for you to come and introduce a song. Ooh, that would be fun. That would be so great. You could sing a song, you could play the drums. I don't even sing in the shower.
谢谢。是我。我很乐意你能来。我很乐意你能来并介绍一首歌。哦，那会很有趣。那会太棒了。你可以唱首歌，你可以打鼓。我连洗澡时都不唱歌。
You don't want that. But I thank you so, so, so the drums. You could play the guitar. We could just sit out there. I don't even sing in the shower. You don't want that. But I thank you so, so, so, so much for this hour, buddy. Yeah, Jared, it's so great to talk to you. I hate that it's gotta be a podcast so that we can visit, but I'll take what I can get. And good luck. It's an absolute honor to be here with you guys, and I'm really blown away by what you've created.
你不会想听那个的。但我非常、非常、非常感谢你抽出这一个小时，老兄。是的，杰瑞德，和你聊天太棒了。我很讨厌必须通过播客才能叙旧，但我能抓住什么机会就抓什么机会。祝你好运。能和你们在一起绝对是我的荣幸，我对你们所创造的成就感到由衷的震撼。
It's something so special. It's touched so many people. And my brother's gonna be psyched. I didn't tell him I was doing it this morning. Oh, that's cool. He's psyched. Oh great, tell him hi. All right, well enjoy the rest of your four-pounds.
这是如此特别的东西。它触动了那么多的人。我弟弟一定会兴奋坏了。我今天早上没告诉他我要来上节目。哦，那太酷了。他很兴奋。哦，太棒了，替我向他问好。好吧，那就享受剩下的四磅吧。
My first podcast, so thank you. You crushed it. You crushed it. You absolutely destroyed it. Apologies to everyone if I fucked it up, but I need a little practice. No, you did not. No, you killed it, man.
我的第一个播客，所以谢谢你们。你们太棒了。你们太棒了。你们简直大获成功。如果我搞砸了，向大家道歉，但我需要多加练习。不，你没有。不，你太棒了，老兄。
You killed it. Thanks, Jared. I appreciate it. Thanks for being you did not. No, you killed it, man. You killed it. Thanks, Jared. I appreciate it. Thanks for being here, Jared. Thank you, Jared. We love you, we love you. Jared Leto, wow. Look, I'm gonna put this on.
你太棒了。谢谢你，杰瑞德。我很感激。谢谢你来，杰瑞德。谢谢你，杰瑞德。我们爱你，我们爱你。杰瑞德·莱托（Jared Leto），哇。听着，我要把这个戴上。
There you go. You can do that or you can slam it. Yeah. That is, that's Jared Leto. I just, I love the guy. He's just always so smooth and personable, honest, real. Yeah, I could have talked to him for two more hours. Yeah, okay, well, we'll get a number for him
给你。你可以戴着它，也可以把它摔了。是的。那就是，那是杰瑞德·莱托。我就是，我太喜欢这家伙了。他总是那么圆滑、随和、诚实、真实。是的，我可以跟他再聊两个小时。是的，好吧，我们会拿到他的电话号码，
and then we'll make that happen. But, you know, he's like, I didn't want to embarrass him with the acting stuff, because I know that, like Joaquin, like they're both, like, for my money, top five actors in the world. And they just don't like to talk about how fucking great they are and the roles that they do and the process of it.
然后我们会促成此事。但是，你知道，他就像是，我不想用演戏的事让他感到尴尬，因为我知道，就像华金（Joaquin）一样，他们两个，在我看来，都是世界上前五名的演员。而他们就是不喜欢谈论他们有多他妈的优秀、他们扮演的角色以及背后的创作过程。
Probably our listeners don't wanna hear about that shit either, the process. But he's fucking so goddamn good. Yeah, he's so good, JB, and you're so right. And that is one of those things that those, the great actors all kinda share, which is they don't talk about their process in that way. They're not like, hey, hey, let me show you.
可能我们的听客也不想听那些狗屁倒灶的事情，关于创作过程。但他他妈的太该死的好。是的，他太棒了，JB，你说得太对了。这也是那些伟大的演员们所共有的一点，那就是他们不会以那种方式谈论他们的创作过程。他们不会像，嘿，嘿，让我给你展示一下。
It's like a magician, like I'm not telling you how the fucking trick goes, just enjoy it. Yeah, they're not looking for, they're like, let the performance speak for itself. And then, and I'll talk to you about my life and stuff, but I'm not gonna kinda walk you through so that you're impressed with my process.
这就像魔术师一样，就像我才不会告诉你这个该死的魔术是怎么变的，你只管享受就行了。是的，他们不寻求，他们就像是，让表演本身去说话吧。然后，我可以跟你谈谈我的生活什么的，但我不会带你走一遍，好让你对我的创作过程印象深刻。
Right, or you're starting to identify those things you heard him talk about the next time you see the performance instead of like enjoying sort of like pretending that he's somebody else, which is all it's about, it's simple. Right. Well, he's good, it's decided, he's really good at what he does. Yeah, and a good example. Right. Yeah. Well, he's good. It's decided. He's really good at what he does.
对，否则下次你看到这个表演时，你开始去识别那些你听他谈论过的事情，而不是去享受那种假装他是一个完全不同的人的过程——这本来就是全部的意义，很简单。对。好吧，他很优秀，就这样定了，他在他做的事情上真的很出色。是的，也是个好人。对。是的。好吧，他很优秀。就这样定了。他在他做的事情上真的很出色。
Yeah, and a good dude. And by the way, what he does, and then he has this, and it's so, it's odd to. It's a full blown rock band. Yeah, you can't call it a sideline. Yeah, no, I know. It's arguably more successful than his acting career. Potentially, I mean, 15 million albums,
是的，而且是个好小伙。顺便说一句，他所做的事，然后他还有这个，太，这真奇怪。这是一个成熟的摇滚乐队。是的，你不能称之为副业。是的，不，我知道。这可以说是比他的演技生涯还要成功。潜在地，我的意思是，1500万张专辑，
and it's been around for 26 years and they're playing arenas? You know, come on. That's like winning an Oscar every year. That works so hard. He works harder than obviously Sean right now working on a buy. Because I guess he has.
而且已经存在了26年，他们还在体育馆里演出？你知道的，拜托。那就像每年都赢得奥斯卡奖一样。他工作太努力了。他工作肯定比现在正在努力买东西的肖恩还要努力。因为我猜他有。
No, I was just gonna say. No, I was looking at. Fucking watching your face is embarrassing. I was going to look at what he wanted to ask you for, because I know he wanted to ask you for him. What was the name of the movie? What was it called? You tell us. It was Dallas Buyers Club.
不，我正要说。不，我在看。他妈的看你的脸真令人尴尬。我本来想看他想向你借什么东西，因为我知道他想向你借……那部电影叫什么名字？叫什么来着？你告诉我们。是《达拉斯买家俱乐部》（Dallas Buyers Club）。
Bye. Beautiful sign. Bye. I can see you. Sorry, bye. Smart. Bye! I can see you... But, sorry, bye. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armgerve, Bennett Barbicoe, and Michael Granteri. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。美丽的金饰。再见。我能看见你。抱歉，再见。真聪明。再见！我能看见你……但是，抱歉，再见。SmartLess是由罗布·阿姆格维（Rob Armgerve）、贝内特·巴尔比科（Bennett Barbicoe）和迈克尔·格兰特里（Michael Granteri）100%有机且手工匠心制作的。这一期节目目前还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。